häufig ist wieder vorbei waren und heute
möchte ich euch von meinem bruder
erzählen und nicht so nebenbei in einem
u bahn und auch nicht in einem instagram
post sondern so richtig face to face und
euch gleich erzählen warum wir auf eine
kamelfarm gefahren sind macht man ja so
als geschützter klar mein bruder war
schon immer eine sehr besondere person
für mich er ist ein jahr älter als ich
und deswegen war auch schon in der
kindheit so mein held alles was er
gemacht hat war cool richtig cool ich
heute über die gleiche frisur haben wie
er was ich dann auch irgendwann mal
bekommen habe keine so gute idee sehe
ich jetzt ein
aber damals war er einfach mein großer
held beim großer held ist er noch bis
heute und es liegt auch zu einem großen
teil an seiner lebensgeschichte und wie
er damit umgehe im september 2008 ist
etwas passiert was unsere familien vor
eine große herausforderung gestellt hat
und zwar ist mein bruder mitten im
unterricht da war gerade in der neuen
klasse erst umgekippt und hat einen
herzstillstand gab der herzstillstand
war die folge aus einer krankheit die
vorher keiner bemerkt hat und in
kombination dadurch dass er längere zeit
erkältet war war sein herzmuskel
geschwächt und dann ist es zu dem
herzstillstand gekommen wo er dann lange
lange erstmal vom schulsanitätsdienst
dienst wiederbelebt wurde weil sie ihn
quasi immer wieder verloren haben
bis dann der krankenwagen kam und ihnen
auch weiterhin versucht hat zu
reanimieren und dann wurde er ins
krankenhaus gebracht und dann in ein
anderes krankenhaus gebracht also dann
lag eine lange zeit im koma ist ein
bisschen schwierig darüber zu sprechen
aber ich bin nicht der profi darüber und
wenn meine mutter ist dieses video sieht
dann wird sie sich am kopf fassen und
sagen nein du musst das so erzählen und
du musst das sehen weil das war genau so
und so hat ist im gartenhaus an vielen
stellen haben viele erste wirklich
versagt das weiß ich dass kann ich auch
begreift und da ist es dann so dazu
gekommen dass mein bruder heute im
rollstuhl sitzt und quasi blind ist also
der sieg natürlich wenn susanne oder
schatten also wechselt ihr erkennt aber
also er sieht nichts und jetzt
tatsächlich euch noch immer ein held
deswegen ist das ist alles vor ein
bisschen über zehn jahren passiert und
am anfang war ich immer noch so
eingestellt dass ich dachte ach ja das
brauchen jetzt drei jahre und er kann
bald wieder laufen und an
was man sie ins auge setzen kann oder
das gehirn dass er dann auch wieder
sehen kann und vielleicht mit der
homepage oder vielleicht bietet das sind
das nicht können aber ich war immer der
meinung so bald bei ist alles wieder
normal
so schnell geht das aber nicht
viele dinge brauchen zeit und ihr müsst
euch mal vorstellen dass ihr zehn jahre
daran arbeitet wieder laufen zu können
wieder eure hände richtig koordinieren
zu können und vielleicht wieder sehen zu
können wenn ich daran denke wie viele
sagt nicht aufgeht weil ich sich nicht
nach zwei wochen wäre ja schön muss ich
sagen respekt quito du weißt möglich wie
man arbeit und jetzt komme ich dazu
waren wir auch die kamelfarm gefahren
sind sony pictures hat mich gefragt hey
vanessa am 21
kommt ein neuer film in die kinos die
goldfische hast du lust dafür auf eine
kamelfarm zu fahren und ich sehe warum
auch eine kamelfarm in dem film geht es
um ein reger gruppe die auf eine
kamelfarm fährt er ja hammer kann ich
auf meinen bruder mitnehmen er ja klar
warum nicht
genauso nikab oder diese france jörg
rusch und jetzt noch mal ganz kurz zum
film handelt von oliver einem banker der
auf der überholspur lebt aber irgendwann
auf der autobahn einen unfall baut und
im rollstuhl land wie ihr euch
vorstellen könnt ist oliver nicht so
ganz happy mit seiner situation und dazu
hat er noch ein anderes problem er muss
geld aus der schweiz nach deutschland
bringen war dass ich so schwarz gelb hat
da nicht so offiziellen und was macht er
nimmt seine truppe mit und möchte dann
undercover mit denen auch eine kamelfarm
fahren gemäht paaren sind zum brecher
denn welche polizei würde einen bus mit
lauter behinderten
menschen durchsuchen keine sau
kontrollierten brust von rd ich würde
das sicher nicht machen und was alles so
passiert wenn ein mädchen mit down
syndrom eine blinde ein autist einem
rollstuhl auch eine kamelfarm fahren
das medium film und somit hamann bruder
mich uns losgemacht auf den roadtrip
unseres lebens
[Musik]
die autofahrer hat die freude
und da brauchen wir genügend verwiesen
m
bonn
beschreiben kamel das nicht die
festzuschreiben
nicht angekommen bei der farben wurden
wir auch vorzüglich begrüßt von meinen
absoluten absoluten lieblingstieren
alpakas und lamas wie du es findet sich
die welt
entschuldigung können sie mir weiter
helfen wo wir ihn zu den kamelen ja
genau zu den kamelen ich mir wir müssen
wir müssen einmal zu euren kollegen wie
ging nochmal dann einfach über nacht
später
[Musik]
das ist dann nicht ausgeschlossen mit
dem komischen er hat noch nie freut
hässliches gesehen
[Gelächter]
was kamele für bereiche machen und ein
bruder
und da ist unsere ganz persönliche
führung auch schon los erst konnten wir
uns von brauchen ein paar camille
anschauen wir sagen ob wir hier auch was
findet ihr hier seien die tiere sind
groß manchmal ein
[Musik]
aber nicht dass sie aus dem beleidigt
und dann ging es für uns in ein kamel
stall und wir haben so viel über das
wesen von kamelen gelernt des und so
beruhigende tiere und sie mal von so nah
zu sehen war wirklich so krass und es
gab sogar kleine babys die zwei wochen
alt waren
wer mit dem zimmer geht ja so die
nächsten drei wochen kann sich aber zu
welchem er steigt dann sauber gemacht
hinter dir und du lernst einfach mit den
kamelen sowie tat von der bei den wölfen
aufgewachsene
märz unter euch jetzt wieder leute gibt
die eigentliche punkte haben der sie
jetzt gerne meckern wollen und an den
tierhaltung und kamele können doch
eigentlich nach ägypten lebt darüber im
netz will ist euch bevor ihr jetzt
kommentare schreibt denn so wie uns das
erklärt wurde und erzählt wurde den
kamelen geht es wirklich super das ist
für die 1 5 sterne hotel zeigt euch ganz
ehrlich aber natürlich wollen wir auch
kamele streichen und ich dachte noch
irgendwie vielleicht mit kamelen nicht
reiten können dass es dann auch nicht so
sinn macht diese farm zu besuchen
aber allein diese kamele zu streichen
und zu hören was sie für geräusche
machen hat mein bruder glaube ich schon
so gefallen dass mein herz ist einfach
nur die erdgeschoss und ich dachte mir
so oh mein gott
jede woche angefahren und möchtest das
ist so heiß war
[Musik]
so viel habe ich ein kleines
das ist ein bisschen abfällt weil das
bei dem winter schon ein bisschen vorbei
und jahre hier so zwischen den
kinderzimmern herbst das ist total weich
obwohl das ja von meinem kopf runter
gefallen
[Musik]
doch dort bot
ich glaube mein bruder und sindbad sich
auch sehr nahe ich glaube ich hab noch
gesehen wie sie handynummern
ausgetauscht haben immer wenn ich mit
meinem bruder unterwegs bin ist es toll
zu sehen wie man auch mit anderen sinnen
arbeiten kann beziehungsweise wieviel
geräusche auch ausmachen
dadurch dass ich sehen kann 80 nicht auf
geräusche so sehr wie er heißt wenn ein
schaf irgendwie gemäht hat oder eine
ziege da irgendwie ein geräusch gemacht
hat oder ein kamel oder ein pferd oder
irgendwas er hat immer sofort darauf
reagiert weil das war für ihn dass alle
spannendste diese tiere live zu hören zb
die pferde und zebra stadt hat ein pferd
so laute geräusche gemacht wunder saß da
und hat einfach gesagt ja es ist nicht
so wie im fernsehen wenn man das live
hört aber in leipzig
also mir fehlt das hat er aber ich muss
sagen so auch wer sein favorit also kido
ich beschreibt sie die museen aus dem
zebrastreifen das wirklich das ist das
süßeste mensch der welt ich mal richtig
traurig bin dann rufe ich mein bruder an
ich weiß nicht warum woher er diese gabe
hat weil früher als wir so ein bisschen
da waren dabei so dabei eher so ein
arsch da wäre ich zu ihm gekommen bin
ich traurig wäre aber heute warte er hat
immer so aufbauende worte einheit ist
und am ende doch du mein bruder sogar
noch sein lieblingstier streichen
ein hund kann dinge ich muss aber auch
sagen bauen die war so unglaublich süß
und spätestens jetzt sollte auch dem
letzten aufgefallen sein dass mein
bruder trotz seiner behinderung und
einschränkung denn wirklich kurze typ
ist und mein bester freund und ich hab
den echt so lieb idol falls du das jetzt
hörst du schön dass du da bist von
aufwendungen drei stunden autofahrt renn
weiß ich dass ich immer auf mich zählen
kann und darf ist ein geschwister david
und falls die selbe geschwister habt
vergesst nicht ihnen auch mal zu sagen
dass sie gerne habt oder den zu zeigen
dass ihr euch freut dass sie in eurem
leben sind in geschwister hat man ein
leben lang und das sind die menschen die
man sich zwar nicht ausgesucht hat aber
die alles von mir kennen und das ist
schön und um das emotional ruder
herumzureißen ich würde mich wirklich
freuen wenn ihr euch den film anschaut
es ist mir ein persönliches anliegen
weil ich merke dass menschen mit
behinderungen natürlich ein teil der
gesellschaft sind und natürlich haben
die meisten menschen nichts gegen
menschen mit behinderung das ist auch
klar aber ich merke es bis heute dass
menschen angst behinderten haben angst
davor etwas falsches zu sagen falsche
mit ihnen umzugehen und und deswegen ist
man keinen sesam endlich aber ich glaube
so einen film wie die goldfische kann
dazu beitragen ein stück mehr
menschlichkeit in behinderte reinfeldt
ich möchte gerne dieses thema
behinderung auf locker aber gleichzeitig
angst etwas zu sagen wenn man mir dann
das wort an verdrehen kann und sagen
kann er ja natürlich sind menschen mit
behinderung normal
warum musst du das denn jetzt so betonen
so deswegen will ich nur sagen leute
schaut sich den film an
ich glaube er macht was ich werde mich
auf den bahnsteig ich muss jetzt in die
schweiz man fast keine sau
kontrollierten bus von erbeben
noch mal so richtig sind die inneren
werte ich sagte was machst du
erfährst du sogar blind ist es oft die
goldfische den führerschein würde ich
gerne mal gesehen
mein name steht auf dem schild wie
spricht man saß im kino und daheim
pictures für die kooperation das geld
geht direkt in die reha in polen wo man
bruder die in sechs wochen verbringen
wird also viel spaß quito ich hoffe die
therapie machen viel spaß und die polen
nämlich nicht zu hart rahmen die
komponieren das video einen daumen nach
oben geben uns vielleicht eure
geschichten mit ihren geschwistern
teilen wenn ihr wollt oder auch nicht
bis dann